jesus lozardo today his 14th start
21st game of the season is eighth with
the marlins and so far in seven starts
the era has been high
however he has been better his last two
starts
and
one kind of number within that holly has
also been the lack of walks out in front
of three or four change-ups
and time goes to the curveball
for his first strikeout
tonight javi hits one out to right
center field deep back in the gap and
short hops goes over the wall for a
ground rule double
so bias who more and more has been using
the opposite field another drive to the
opposite gap and he's got himself a two
out double
two on two out two and two to conforto
and he bounces that one and taking off
for third is bias and he's safe
taking a gamble with two outs trying to
move up on a very
short
dirt ball
he would have been out he kind of gave
him the old okie doke here that's the
second time baez has uh kind of pulled
the old trickster slide and conforta
walks in here comes bias on the wild
pitch with the first run of the game
so by getting to third with two out on a
wild pitch bias is able to score on the
very next pitch
it was ball four to conforto bias comes
home with the first run of the night and
it's one nothing new york well there's
marcus
this will be his 30th start of the year
excuse me 9-12 that record is not
indicative of how well he's pitched but
at this point of the season now
everybody needs to put their nose to the
grindstone and they got to come up aces
all she's going to do is
get it past strowman right
it's popped up shallow left dom into
foul ground almost overrated and he did
now dom hasn't played a couple of weeks
and you could see it from that play
misjudged that ball and overran it he's
hitting 342 through his first 117 big
league at bats and he flies this one out
to right center field and porto should
have plenty of room
and that retires the side so strowman
works a 1-2-3 opening inning mets with a
one-nothing lead after one
that time
down on strikes
goes to the breaking ball and luzardo
gets the strikeout
two in the inning four in the game one
nothing mets
contra just drew raves from everybody
last night for his performance 14
strikeouts in nine innings
throwing a hundred in the ninth inning
and that sinker at the knees first call
third strike and strowman's got his
first strike out of the night
strowman's 26th pitch of the inning
coming up
and a little flick into left center
field but that goes lindor to get it and
that retires the side
sierra trying to dump one in and lender
got a great jump on that ball to end the
end
double to right center took third
on a wild pitch scored on a wild pitch
this one's deep to center back to sierra
takes a look and it's out of here javi
bias into the green
his 29th home run of the year
it's been the bias show so far tonight
it's two nothing new york
dead central 438 feet away 29th home run
for bias is seventh as a met
a double his first time up
and now a home run to make it two
nothing
and the slider in for a call third
strike lucardo caught looking second
strikeout for strowman one down in the
third
swinging a miss good slider by stroma to
strike out rojas so back-to-back
strikeouts for marcus to start the third
little chopper strowman gets this one
and the backhand flip to alonso for the
out so strowman wasn't gonna let a
second one go by
and then javier by as a home run to dead
center
this one back behind second jazz goes
out ranging and makes the play over his
shoulder
what a play by jazz in center field for
the first out
we've seen the middle infielders all
series long making uh over the shoulder
catches both for the mets and jazz as
well
very good athleticism kind of like a
wide receiver
one ball and two strikes here it comes
to the met's left fielder waved at and
missed the breaking ball for luzardo
strikeout number five
pitch to mccann a swing and a miss a
fastball
upstairs for luzardo that's six
swinging to miss and de la cruz is down
on strike stroman's got his good slider
going tonight he sure does that's his
fourth strikeout
jesus sanchez pulls one diving stop by
alonso falling down he makes the throw
on target
beautifully done by alonso
first the dive then getting to his knee
and then falling sideways
but throwing accurately to stroman to
get the out ranger suarez gives up a run
that's a big deal 1.4 era
let's chopped back to strowman
handles that one with the plum
10 in a row retired by marcus he's
through five scoreless innings with a
two-nothing lead
and he's going
swung and missed throw by leone and
he's safe
again it looked like he pulled the hand
away yeah and he didn't have to he
thought he thought he was called out he
was asking the mets to challenge the
call thinking he had been called out
because he he went with the headset
again he pulls the hand away and he got
into the base it's the second time he's
done that tonight there goes baez swung
and missed from his knees leon can't be
handled by diaz
and bias has his second stolen base of
the inning
but here he gets conforto to chase
and that's eight strikeouts for
jesus
and he matches a career high in
strikeouts the second time he's gotten
to eight with the marlins
and a called strike three inside corner
nicely done by zach popp
the base runners have been few and far
between tonight for miami
to the right side baez lindor
and jazz beats it out
scores gets away from
alonso
and rbi for
jazz and the marlins are within a run
one two coming
two semer caught the inside corner
strike three call
six strikeouts for strowman and he keeps
the mets in the lead 2-1 after six
one-two coming to diaz and he got him
strowman strikes out lewin diaz that's
seven tonight for marcus one down in the
seventh and that's going to be it for
strowman
that's a good of the bullpen
strowman of exit after six in the third
tying running second that's issan diaz
another payoff pitch on the way
princeton little tapper hand
over to get it throws and it's off the
mark it gets into right field here comes
[Applause]
bender pitched in the 10th inning
yesterday and was the winning pitcher
and pete gets one in the air to right
field well hit back on sanchez to the
warning track at the wall it's off the
fence bouncing away from sanchez alonzo
the second he's going to take the turn
he's going to try for three alonzo
slides in safely with a triple
pedal lonzo with an opposite field three
base hit to start the top of the eighth
inning
ground ball miggy's there
throws to first and blyer cleans up a
little mess
the leadoff triple is stranded tied last
to the eighth
jazz gets set to
head to the plate with two outs
and jazz hits one a ton
that
is gone into the upper deck
jazz chisholm junior gives the marlins
an eighth inning lead
what a moment for jazz joseph my
goodness what a swim
trying to knock down his ninth save of
the year one ball and two strikes swing
hit on this
it's a marlins win
you